[Music]
my book edge of chaos offers ten
proposals to improve democracy roughly
six of them are targeting the politician
four of them are targeting the voter it
is critically important that people
appreciate as we go through these very
challenging proposals that all the
proposals all ten of them have precedent
somewhere in the world so to put it more
simply every proposal that I offer in
the book for consideration not for
wholesale consumption but for us to
consider as we think about our unique
Democratic circumstances in whatever
country we may be all of these proposals
have do exist already somewhere around
the world for instance I offer the idea
of mandatory voting there are about 27
countries today that have mandatory
voting including Australia Belgium
Greece and many countries in South
America the idea is very simple it's
essentially an endowed civic duty of
every citizen to participate in the
electoral process and it's critically
important that people do participate and
so what they do in Australia is that
they find new and actually in many
countries I should say for a way the
mandatory voting is the case you either
get a monetary fine or you could be
blocked from public services such as you
may not be able to get a job in the
government if you do not vote and if you
do not have proof that you vote of
course there are many other things we
can think about to try and enhance voter
participation rates especially to the
extent that people are not voting
because they are too poor to leave say
an hourly wage job to go and stand in
line it could be the case that we might
seem more you know people vote on a
weekend instead of on a Tuesday in
November we might actually subsidize
some of those you know workers on the
day of the election so that they don't
feel like they're losing income so some
of these initiatives are already
underway in other places across Europe
as an example I do think that we should
think about trying to enhance the
participation of voters made frankly
this idea of mandatory voting does fly
in the face of the First Amendment in
the United States which is the right to
choose but I do think that you know this
is actually harm
us especially if we add stealth are
essentially moving to an environment
where fewer and fewer people vote and
essentially then dictate if albeit
implicitly dictate public policies so I
do think we should be open to the
questions around mandatory voting but
nevertheless it is worth saying that I
think that that might be a hard pill to
swallow for Americans who do believe in
the First Amendment and one of the other
proposals for voters is this idea of
weighted voting and it has already been
misunderstood I my book has been
reviewed a number of times and it's
quite a pity that people are
misconstruing and misunderstanding what
it's about
it is about allocating greater or less
weight to people based on their
engagement this is not about ascribing
higher weights to people based on any
adjectives such as race or gender or
land ownership or IQ or education it has
absolutely nothing to do with that just
to be absolutely clear but there there
are of course contextual issues because
we would not want to return to an era of
where certain groups are essentially
disadvantaged or banished from voting
because of their backgrounds or race or
education I have to say as an immigrant
as somebody who's immigrated to Europe
but also to the United States I am
required to take a civics test every
immigrant regardless of background
economics standing or education
background is required to take a basic
test to show that engagement and all I'm
essentially proposing in the book is
that we might want to consider that kind
of thinking just so that we can imbue a
sense of commitment from the average
citizen of course there are places in
fact Canada and Switzerland are looking
at weighted voting you could see the
idea of weighted voting perhaps getting
much more aggressive if you think about
a referendum in referenda it's usually a
very specific question that is on the
ballot and so for example you could
argue and some people have argued that
for a health care question you know
frankly I don't know whether the margin
dollar or the additional dollar that we
spend in healthcare should go for x-rays
or for beds or for nurse nurses pay I
simply don't know but maybe the people
who work in that area might have better
understanding a better understanding of
what the best use of that additional
dollar might be and so this idea that
their vote should count more is
something that is definitely flirted
around is similarily with with education
as well but this is very much around
referenda it's not about general
elections and again I think there's a
bit of a schism in thinking there I will
just point out that we already do have
weighted voting in the United States if
you are incarcerated you have a zero
vote there's about two million Americans
but also an exacta two million Americans
who are in prison today but that
excludes people who are released and not
allowed to vote but also in the
Democratic Party super-delegates have a
weight that weighs more than the average
delegate so whether people are aware or
not we do have these these sort of
themes of weighted voting already but
hopefully we that ultimately what we
want what I think was the ultimate win
for democratic processes to ensure we
have as many people as possible voting
but we want to make sure that people are
also very understanding or certainly
engaged as possible and I believe that
having these types of proposals in place
will address these particular goals in a
very specific way it may be worth just
adding one last point which is that
ultimately if we had mandatory civics
classes or courses let's say at high
school or even junior high I think that
would also really help because there are
many studies that now show upwards of a
third of American adults don't even know
the three key pillars of the democratic
process the executive the legislature as
well as the judiciary and to me I think
that ultimately we have an it is our
duty and onus to ensure that we have
better participation of engage and and
engagement of citizens and part of that
process is ensuring that they understand
what voter rights are how the process
works and how to vote
as well as participate in a meaningful
way
[Music]